I think uh this manipulation this  gaslighting this bullion is giving birth  to certain people that are saying you  know what I'm done I I got plenty of  money I'm getting in the game you guys  are doing too much I'm gonna come and  expose the living [ __ ] at you and it's  not going to be pretty and those guys  are now finding each other okay just  like complainers always find each other  crap magnets always find each other in a  company environment you always notice  seven people go to lunch together if  three of them are complainers the other  four are also complainers they just  found each other if you see five people  two of them are studs go to lunch the  other three are also studs because they  find each other these Fighters are now  finding each other saying hey what do  you got going on let me get your message  out let me get your message out what do  you got and then okay now there's some  power so